now to china where the opening ceremony
of the winter olympics is underway in
beijing these olympics as you know are
hugely controversial why china has been
widely criticized for human rights
abuses including the mistreatment of
pro-democracy activists and ethnic
minorities the athletes though they are
focused on their events which started
ahead of today's ceremony jamie yukas is
covering the olympics in beijing where
they can really say let the games begin
jamie good morning
good morning the chinese national
stadium known as the bird's nest which
you can sort of see with those red
lights right over my shoulder here it is
filled with athletes from all over the
world but is short on diplomats after
the u.s australia canada and the uk
refused to send the usual diplomatic
delegation in protest of china's human
rights violations
organizers of the opening ceremony hope
to ignore the politics and broadcast to
the world their vision and theme for the
games together for a shared future for
the parade of nations a twist for team
usa teammates chose curling legend john
shuster and bobsledder alanna myers
taylor as flag bearers but britney bowe
will walk for myers-taylor since she's
still stuck in a chinese isolation hotel
after a positive covet test are you so
excited that you were named a flag bear
i'm a first
generation immigrant
and so to have all that history and to
know what the american flag means to my
family like it is huge to be asked to
carry it myers-taylor recently spoke out
to critics who say she and other
athletes should boycott the games over
china's human rights record in an op-ed
for usa today she acknowledged those
concerns but wrote to go to beijing and
compete as an american a woman a person
of color and as a special needs parent
says more than any boycott could
beijing is the first city to host both
summer and winter games and each carried
controversy surrounding human rights
abuses chinese authorities have
countered saying governments should not
bring politics into the olympics the
fact is that sports has been political
from the beginning of time and every
olympics has had an element of politics
in it
the games have already been underway for
a couple of days now this morning u.s
medal hopeful nathan chen skated
flawlessly it was beautiful in a short
program part of the team event is what
took place there and while the u.s
women's hockey team beat finland in
their opener they lost a major player
for the tournament forward briana decker
went down with a major painful injury to
her lower leg nate
jamie yukas in beijing thank you